learning we have yossi who is going to
talk about his really fascinating work
on bats
um jonathan is going to give us a really
yeah so uh let's uh stick to the
schedule and
uh i will i will do just a brief
introduction
so it's really a pleasure to have here
professor mikhail irani from
the whitesman institute of science in
israel and thank you for joining even
though it's i think pretty late here
already in israel so uh mikhail did your
phd at the hebrew university of
jerusalem
then uh was at some time um at princeton
and uh she is uh very well known
probably one of the the most important
figures in computer vision in israel and
not only
and i remember when i was a student
and was also working in in this field or
justin fields
mikhail already was a legend at least in
the sense that i think she
never had any paper rejected from
tvpro
but at least that was the saying so that
she managed to to publish without any
rejection
in in these conferences which are really
cut forward and the
acceptance rate is very low so and today
he will be talking about
uh her recent work on uh how to do
deep learning with zero shot deep
learning
so after such an introduction i think i
should probably stop here because from
here it can only go downhill
[Laughter]
anyway um so uh thanks for the
introduction
so uh i'm not doing i'm not gonna talk
about communication not human
communication and not non-human
communication
so how is this relevant to the workshop
and what is this all about
what i'd like to tell you is how we can
learn from very very little data
often no data at all no prior examples
simply by exploiting the internal
structure of the test
data itself and since i come from
computer vision i'm going to
show this on images but i believe this
goes well beyond
computer vision i believe it goes it
applies to other domains as well as
other
structured signals and hopefully also
for non-human
signals so um
what is deep internal learning the idea
is how we can train a deep network in a
totally unsupervised way
by simply on with no prior examples
whatsoever
by training on a single image the test
image alone
okay and we do this by training on
examples extracted from the test image
we train the network using these
now why is this interesting well we're
all used to what i call external
learning that is to say we train a
network on lots of examples external
examples
that are given to us prior to the test
data and we train
the network for days or weeks and then
once it's trained we apply it to new
test data we never saw before and of
course this has been
tremendously successful but what happens
if we don't have enough training data
or what happens if the statistics of our
test data is very different than that of
the training data
it turns out that in those cases deep
learning does quite poorly
what i'd like to show is how we can
often resolve these problems by
replacing external learning
with internal learning and as i'll show
you this has a wide range of
applications in computer vision
including super resolution spatial super
resolution images
temporal super resolution and video
image dehazing
image segmentation transparency
separation retargeting all without ever
having seen any prior examples and
i'll also show our new work on mind
reading how we can decode brain activity
fmri data with very little fmri data
and reconstruct the images that the
person saw
and you'll also see that there we train
on the test datum as well
which is in this case uh fmri data
also the test fmri data so let's start
so how can we learn how can we train on
a single image well
let's look let's look at this a single
image has lots of recurrence inside it
uh the recurrence occurs both within the
scale the original scale of the image as
well as across different scales of the
image when i say that
there is recurrence within scale i mean
that if you see a small patch once
inside the image
you'll almost surely see it many more
times in in the image now here i'm
showing relatively large
patches for visualization purposes but
in practice i'm talking about
much smaller patches five pixels by five
pixels or seven 7x7
and this has been used by us and by
others for lots of different
applications in computer vision
including image completion uh image
denoising like non-local means pm 3d etc
visual summarization and many other
applications less commonly known but
also very useful
is the recurrence of information across
scales in the image that is to say if i
take the image
and scale it down then patches in the
original scale
will almost surely appear as is in
downscaled version of the image without
scaling down the patch
which means the little small patterns in
the original image appear in multiple
sizes inside the image
and again i'm talking about much smaller
patches than what you see here
and this property has been used by us
and by others for a lot of many
applications include including fractal
image compression super resolution from
a single image
blind blurring blind dehazing and many
more now you can say this looks like a
very contrived image and does this
really go beyond
images with such repetitive structure
and the answer is yes
if you go to small patches five by five
seven by seven
this property is true for almost any
patch in almost
any natural image for example if you
look at this image with no clear
repetitive structure
then look at this patch over here this
edge patch it repeats many more times
along this
window seal or similarly uh across
scales
this edge patch recurs again here
without scaling down the patch
or this corner patch again i'm showing
large patches i'm talking about much
smaller ones
so you can say okay repetitive structure
edges corners
what happens if i take unstructured
information like this
well let's zoom in and see this and you
can see that the information is quite
repetitive across scales you see the
same statistical structures
and uh we uh uh empirically verified
that this
very strong fractal-like property is
very very strong in natural images and
you can find this in our 2009 paper we
empirically verified this for hundreds
of natural images
indoor outdoor man-made natural and it
turns out that this is true for almost
any patch in almost any image
so as i said this gave rise to lots of
applications over the past decade or two
and the real nice thing about it it's
totally unsupervised i don't need any
external examples all i need is the
single test image
and i can solve ilpo's problem simply by
exploiting this strong prior by
maximizing the recurrence of information
within and across scales
of the uh image their recurrence of
patches
the bad news is that in the last few
years it has been completely
outperformed by deep learning methods
so this is very depressing and initially
i was totally depressed for a year or
two and then i said okay
if you can't beat them join them but on
one hand you know it's very unsatisfying
on one hand we have this deep learning
which is amazingly successful
but is extremely data hungry and we
don't really understand what the network
learns
on the other hand we have this very
strong and total redundancy
which we understand it it's totally
unsupervised we don't need any
additional
examples but it doesn't perform well as
deep learning and for a long time i was
asking myself is there any way to
combine the power of these two very
complementary approaches
and luckily three years ago my brilliant
uh phd student the south choco came up
with the idea of doing
deep internal learning that is to say
let's train an image-specific cnn cnn
for those who don't know is a
convolutional neural network
let's train an image-specific cnn at
test time
on examples extracted directly from the
test image and only from that
and as you'll see shortly this can often
be done quite efficiently
so the first problem we looked at was
how we can do super by the way you
you see this thing at the top here
covering my uh
my title of the slide
people is this covering the title of my
site or can you see the title of the
slide
we can see that internal learning
oh you so so it's not nothing is
covering it okay
all right so we started with super
resolution and
the and just to bring you up to the
so that you're on the same page in super
resolution we have a low resolution
image and the goal is
to generate a high resolution image with
uh finer
uh density of pixels now each pixel and
the low resolution image
is affected by certain region within the
high resolution image
it it's a weighted average of several
pixels in the high resolution image what
induces a linear
relation between of convolution and
subsampling between the high resolution
image
and the low resolution one now even if
this kernel k
is known this is still it'll pose
problems because the number of
of the unknowns in our high resolution
image is larger than the number of
knowns the number of pixels we have in
the low resolution image
the problem becomes even more difficult
when this kernel is unknown in which
case we call it blind super resolution
because now we have to recover both
the kernel and the unknown image now i
won't
give you an overview of all the super
resolution methods this goes three
decades ago
but currently the leading methods
are by far uh deep learning based
methods external
learning based methods and their idea is
let's train a network and lots and lots
of examples of low resolution high
resolution image pairs
uh we'll take a network we'll give it as
an input and low resolution image
and it'll have to learn to output the
correct high resolution image
and we can give it as many examples as
we want because all we have to do is
take a good high quality high resolution
image
down scale it and boof we have such a
pair of low resolution high resolution
images
so this is very easy it doesn't require
any manual labeling we can train such
networks for days and then once trained
we can apply it to a new test image that
we never saw before
and out comes the super resolved image
and this
does amazingly well in fact it gave
about 2 db
of improvement in psnr beyond any of the
non-deep
super resolution methods prior to deep
learning but
when we checked we found out that this
these wonderful networks work well only
under ideal conditions
what i mean by ideal conditions is that
first
uh they have a fixed and ideal
downscaling kernel what do i mean by
that
remember we generated our uh low
resolution images by downscaling the
high resolution images when we downscale
an image we blur and subsample it with
some kernel
okay so what do people usually do they
generate the lower resolution images by
blurring a subsample with a relatively
ideal low-pass filter or a bicubic
downscaling kernel
but the world is not ideal when i take a
picture of the world
you know i slightly move my hand this is
not an ideal low pass filter
and you know what when i i'll take
another picture i'll move my hand
slightly differently and it will have a
different downscaling kernel
the downs giving kernel is image
specific it's not even camera specific
it's not even photographer specific
okay and it varies from image for image
and those networks work
really well on bicubicle downscaled
images
but once you take them out of their
comfort zone they don't perform any
better than interpolation
moreover they usually assume no
artifacts in the low resolution images
but real images
have sensor noise have jpeg artifacts
so as i'll show you shortly these once
you take these networks out of their
comfort zone they don't do any better
but sometimes worse than interpolation
more recently
people have started doing blind super
resolution in the last year or two
and the idea there is let's be agnostic
to the downscaling kernel
how can we do that well let's downscale
the high resolution images with a
variety of downscaling kernels
and feed them all to the same network
and that way we'll become agnostic to it
so these methods of course do much
better under unknown
downscaling conditions but still once
you take them out of their comfort zone
out of the type of data they uh trained
on
or out of the type of kernels they
assume they don't perform very well and
i'll show examples
so we said let's uh let's attack this by
replacing the external learning with
internal learning
and this led us to our first work in
this area which we call zero shot cssr
it's not a new nation cssr it's jira
shot super resolution
okay and the idea is here's our test
data
here's our test image we never saw
anything before in our lives that's the
only image we have
what we're going to do and we want to
super resolve it what we're going to do
is we're going to downscale this image
to generate an even lower resolution
image
and in a moment i'll say how we
downscale it and then we're going to
train a very light
image specific cnn network such that
it will learn how to output back the
original in
low resolution input image once trained
on this image
we're going to now apply this network on
the input image
to generate the super resolved output
image and the rationale here is
that the patches in those two images are
the same there is this strong
cross-scale recurrence of parachutes so
whatever network is good for increasing
the resolution of the patches in this
low resolution image
will also be good for increasing the
resolution of this
low resolution input image by the way
can you see my mouse
if i move it do you see it guys
yes yes we can see it we can see it
that's okay wait
just just a second this downscaling uh
what are the examples you're giving
you're giving the good one and the
downscaled one right
yeah you're getting you're saying i want
to teach a network given this
low resolution image to generate back
this one right so you're giving it pairs
here are the pairs okay and i'm trying
to training the network to get the
origin the the downscaled low resolution
image and to learn how to generate back
the low resolution image
and that's once it's trained on that i
apply it to the low resolution image to
generate the high resolution image
now we train it on uh we to further uh
strengthen it we we train it on
augmentation generated from the low
resolution images
by flipping the image rotating it
down scaling it this generates hundreds
of examples
all generated from the low resolution
image all with the same patch statistics
and this is what gives us this image
specific cnn
okay now what about the downscaling
remember i said that the downscaling is
image dependent
varies from image to image how do we
know how to downscale it to maximize
this recurrence well it turns out that
this can also
be estimated directly from the low
resolution input image
and so we had an initial work on this in
2013
and more recently we found even a way of
computing the correct downscaling kernel
from the image using deep learning and
i'll say a few words about this
uh later on down the line okay
but you can ask of course well how can a
cnn be trained a test time doesn't it
take forever
well let's see what kind of information
we have internally inside a single image
versus externally
outside in a general collection of
images inside in a single image the
patch entropy is very low
patches repeat themselves the
distribution is quite simple the
distribution of patches
whereas outside in a general collection
of natural images
the patch distribution is very very high
this means
that uh and by the way we showed this
empirically in our 2011
paper this means that internally i only
need a light network to learn how to
increase the resolution of this
specific image it doesn't have to know
how to increase resolution of other
images
just this specific image in contrast
the external training super resolution
it requires a very heavy network it has
to learn how to increase
any patch of any natural image it will
ever encounter
it has to memorize how to increase the
resolution of all patches that exist out
there
so these networks trying to ha tend to
have
hundreds of layers tens of millions of
parameters and take forever
uh uh to train okay in fact they usually
take
days or weeks to train our network is a
very
light one it's very fast to train in
fact it takes at
eight seconds on a v800 gpu both to
train and to generate the super resolved
image
and this really gives us super
resolution in the wild
uh it allows us to uh super resolve any
data type
any kernel any scalar aspect ratio you
just tag out all the flight
what did you what you want and this is
what you get so let's look at some
results
here is a low resolution uh input image
with an unknown
downscaling it's not it wasn't
bicubically downscaled it's not an ideal
downscaling
but it's a reasonable image
this is what it looks if you just
interpolate it no uh
no super resolution yet now this is what
happens if you apply
the one of the state-of-the-art
externally trained super resolution
algorithms and if i flicker between the
two you'll barely be able to tell the
difference
there is no diff difference now don't
misunderstand me edsr plus
is an amazing super resolution algorithm
but it does well on bicubically
downscaled images
and once you take it out of its comfort
zone it doesn't do much better than
simple interpolation
in contrast here is the result of the
internally trained
uh super resolution without any prior
examples and if i
flicker between the two you'll see the
significant difference
and the reason there is such a
difference is because we exploit
the image-specific degradation the
image-specific downscaling
and the image-specific recurrence of
data
another example an old photo we
downloaded from the internet post-world
war ii we have no idea how it was
generated those of you who recognize
it's checkpoint charlie uh prior to
building the wall
um here is the result of simple
interpolation
here is the result of the one of the
edsr plus externally trained
again flicker between the two you barely
see any difference because this was not
bicubically downscaled
and here is the result of the internally
uh uh trained
uh and if i flicker between the two
you can see the significant difference
for example look here at the legs of the
man
you can see that we actually recover
information with a small which is
smaller than the pixel size which goes
beyond the nyquist limit of the
uh of the camera or of the image okay or
look at this area over here
or the back of the motorbikes okay and
again it's because we
exploit the image specific degradation
and the image specific uh internal
recurrence
uh here's a jpeg compressed image looks
okay when it's small but if you
super resolve it with an externally
trained uh network
you get not only high resolution of the
signal but also high resolution of the
noise
they cannot tell them apart here is the
result of the internally trained
again if i flicker between the two you
can see that the signal was super
resolved the noise was not
how come well the signals has this nice
cross-scale recurrence property the
noise does not
and so the network learns how to super
resolve the signal but it doesn't know
what to do with the noise
it doesn't generalize to that and here's
another example with a different type of
noise again
we don't know what the noise is we don't
the network doesn't know
uh here is a speckle noise here is the
result of the externally trained
uh edsr plus and here is the result of
our internally trained uh
so it's not perfect we haven't removed
all the noise
but uh again this was trained to do
super resolution not to do denoising
but again because the signal recurs
across scale and noise does not
it learns how to generalize for the
signal and not for the noise
of course we did empirical evaluations
we took hundreds of uh images
first we took we took we checked our uh
we compared ourselves on
ideal images ideal images being uh
bicubically downscaled images no noise
of course we're not state-of-the-art
the external methods that's their bread
and butter they do amazingly well on
them but we
do reasonably well nothing to be
embarrassed about
but once you take uh those images out of
the comfort zone of those
networks to non-ideal images either
non-ideally downscaled or non-ideal
noise
okay then we do one or two db better
than the state-of-the-art method
without having any prior examples
uh now of course as i said you have to
know what the
uh um what the kernel is in order to uh
downscale your image in order to train
it and we said that this downscaling is
limit specific
how do we go about estimating it well
remember all we have
is our low resolution input image
nothing else
we don't know what the high resolution
image is nor the downscaling kernel that
relate the two
and we need this kernel because this is
what we want to down scale our image
with
it turns out that the correct
downscaling kernel the correct super
resolution kernel
is also the kernel that if you down
scale the low resolution input image
with it
will maximize the similarity of patches
across scales
in this low resolution image and this is
something we uh showed in our 2013 paper
and we have an analytic proof of that uh
and then we
at that time in 2013 we solved it using
we posed this as an optimization process
a problem and solved uses using a greedy
algorithm
um more recently uh half a year ago
or a year ago we found a way of
computing this kernel also using
internal learning
on the test image alone and we call this
kernel gan
uh it's a kernel estimation via an
internal gam and those of you who don't
know what the gan
is gana's is short for generative
adversarial networks so i'll explain
this in a second
so remember all we have is our low
resolution input image
and we want to find the correct
downscaling uh we're going to train a
network
a generator which is going to learn
how to down scale correctly the image
okay what is good downscaling the one
that maximizes the similarity of patches
across scale
in the image but we don't have this uh a
downscaled image in order to let the
generator
train on these input outputs all we have
is the input for the generator so how
are we going to get the net
the generator to maximize this
similarity
well we're going to train another
network the discriminator
which is going to get crops sometimes
from the generator image and sometimes
from the
uh original image and it's gonna have to
tell them apart whether
they are real or fake real namely
whether they came from the original
input distribution of patches in the
input image
or whether they're fake came from the
distribution of patches in the
downscaled image
and it will generate a map the
discriminator will generate a map that
will say
whether it believes each and every patch
in the image came from the original
input distribution of patches or from
the generated one
and this the generator tries to fool the
discriminator
to believe that all of these patches are
real
and the discriminator trains to to re to
resolve the difference between the two
so they both get better and better
during trainer training it's like a
police and a criminal okay
each one tries to get better than the
other the criminal tries to get away and
fool the policemen and the policeman
tries to catch
the uh the criminal so these two
networks train together
and once trained once this converges
this double network thing this gan
the generator converges to the correct
down scaling
super resolution kernel now note that
this
uh downscale this generator cannot be
just
any deep neural network okay because a
deep neural network is a non-linear
network
okay it can do lots of things for
example it can generate a garble of
patches or just
a collapse to a single patch in the
image the discriminators say hey that's
great because
this patch does exist in the input image
the generator will be happy because it
fooled the discriminator but this is
obviously
not what we want what we want is for the
generator to satisfy
this linear constraint this convolution
and sub-sampling
okay so this is not just any deep linear
network
in fact this constraint is linear okay
and moreover it can be realized with a
single strided convolution layer
okay if you look at this here is the
image here is the kernel and here is the
output of the generator
right so the generator all it has to
have is a single convolution kernel
with strides of two if you want to down
sample the image by two
and that's it and no non-linearities so
we said great
let's put this as our generator a single
stranded convolution layer
this worked terribly if these were the
original ground truth kernels
then this is what our single strided
generator produced horrible results
okay as you can see all of these are
different downscaling kernels
and as you can see we got terrible
results
and no matter what we did we couldn't
get it to work
until again asaph came up with the
understanding why it's not working
the reason as you all know deep learning
works well
it's usually these networks are usually
over determined they're overexpressed
okay
but the reason they converge to a good
solution is because
there's there are no bad local minima in
deep learning you have a very complex
surface
no matter how you initialize the weights
in your network
it'll converge if you train it it will
converge to a good local minimum if you
have enough training data
but this is not the case here in our
case we have a single
good global minimum the correct kernel k
and no other good
and local minimum and so this can never
work because if i go back
the generator has a highly non-convex
error
surface remember it's not only trying to
optimize this linear constraint it's
also trying to fool the discriminator
okay so it's it's error surface the loss
that it's trying to
to minimize is really highly non-convex
and so if we just uh initialize it with
random weights
we'll never converge to the global
mineral we'll get stuck in some local
minima
and so this will never work but what
does work
is replacing the generator with a deep
linear network
what is a deep linear network a deep
linear network is a deep network
with no non-linearities no values or no
no other non-linearities whatsoever
and if you multiply all the weights you
get the desired the single desired
kernel
so have we gained anything i mean isn't
this exactly identical
and the answer is no in the case of the
single-strided convolution layer
we had a single good global minimum and
no other minima
no other good minima but here in the
deep linear network
we have infinitely many decompositions
of this
single kernel into different possible
weights of the network
for example if this is a possible set of
weights of the network that if you
multiply
them all give this kernel then also this
would be a good solution for the network
if you multiply one layer with the
matrix a
and the next layer with the matrix with
the inverse of a
and this is true of course for any
invertible matrix a and you can do it
between any two layers so you have
infinitely many possible
solutions infinitely many decompositions
of the weight of the network
that will when you multiply them all
will give you this single kernel
and therefore we have infinitely many
good local minima
and now when we initialize our network
with random weights
it converges to a good uh local minimum
and indeed if these were the ground
truth kernels and this was the result of
a single
uh strided linear a single stranded
layer g
this is the result of our deep linear
network g
and it's fine you can see that the
results are very good this solved the
problem
and as far as we know this is the first
practical use
of deep linear networks so far they've
been mostly used by theoreticians
in order to analyze networks and
understand what they're doing
but as far as we know this is the first
time it's been used practically
and i believe that any linear regression
problem subject to
non-linear priors uh this is the way to
go about solving it
using deep linear networks so let's look
at some results
so here is a real image again an old
image of john kennedy we have no idea
how it was generated
uh let's look at these two areas what
you see here
are the two uh winners of the
blind super resolution challenge in uh
cbpr 2018 in a workshop called entire
2018
and you can see that they perform quite
poorly now they did very well
on the data set of the the challenge
data set of the of the workshop
but they overfit that dataset once you
take them out of their comfort zone they
don't do very well
what you see here are the result on the
right column is the result
of our uh of zssr where the kernel was
estimated using kernel gun this is all
using internal learning on this single
test image
and you can see that the image is quite
corrupted but you can see
look at the pupils that it recovered
over here you cannot see them in any of
these images
okay they look very smooth because
that's what they were trying to do
but they don't recover the correct
information what you see here in the
third column
is the result of our old method the
non-deep method for computing the kernel
when that is fed into cssr and you can
see that it still
does much better than these methods but
the kernel the internal
the deep internal learning to compute
the kernel does better
how can i sure just about the previous
slide so just to
understand so the difference between the
single layer
so this uh and uh and the d plate a a
linear it's just that you're doing the
same thing so like your
your decision functions of going to the
next layer are just linear
and yes instead of something uh
non-linear but you go
several layers so you do randomization
after that again and so and so forth and
you're saying that that by itself
you can prove you have infinitely many
solutions for this network
for this network you have a single
solution a single combination of weights
that you have to find for the generator
in order to be correct
this generator although the final
solution will be the same
has infinitely many uh solutions there
are infinitely many
weight decompositions of this network
with the same architecture
that if you multiply them all will give
you the same kernel
okay so there's something to prove
analytically it's not sort of obvious
what that's something you move
analytically it's not obvious
we don't have an analytic proof of that
actually
okay that was an intuition uh we don't
have an analytic proof that now it will
converge
of course you have an analytic proof
that it will have infinitely many
solutions but it's not
necessary we cannot prove that any
initial random choice of weights will
necessarily converge
to a good local minimum for that we
don't have a proof but the fact that you
have infinitely many local minima
that is very i just proved it to you
here okay if this is a good local
minimum
then so is this one if you multiply this
layer by
the weights of this layer by a matrix a
and the weights of this later
and there are infinitely many such
possibilities and this network
has only a single solution now you
randomly initialize your weights
in a network you don't know how to
initialize them this will never converge
and this turns out to converge okay but
we cannot
prove the convergence okay we don't have
an analytic proof of that uh
so here's another image and here you can
see the results and once again
the result with estimating the kernel
with the kernel again and then
putting it into our method uh did best
we also did empirical evaluations uh we
outperformed any of the blind and
non-blind methods
for super resolution the externally
trained uh uh
by half to one db that was true at the
time the submission of our paper
that was a year and a half ago submitted
to nips 2019
uh since then many new methods have come
out i'm sure many of them are better
than ours
but i'm glad to say that the new uh
challenge winners of entire 2020
which was a month ago uh won the
challenge
and he is using our kernel gan in order
to estimate
the uh the kernel for each and every new
test image he's externally turning
training to things but the estimation of
the kernel is done using our kernel gap
all right so far i've only shown you
things how we can use deep internal
learning for super resolution and we saw
that this gives us an image specific cnn
and the nice thing is it's totally
unsupervised it requires nothing but the
input
image it adapts itself to the unknown
image specific degradation
and it provides state-of-the-art results
on real non-ideal images
but then we ask ourselves well can we
take it to other domains to other
problems
can we use it for image segmentation
segmenting an imaging to foreground and
background layer
taking a image taken under fog and
dehazing it defogging it
uh taking uh transparent superimposed
transparent layers and
decomposing it into the individual
layers
and the answer is yes it turns out that
all of these tasks
can be solved using deep internal
learning with no prior examples
in fact all these three seemingly
different tasks
can all be solved in a unified manner
and put under a single umbrella
as a layer decomposition problem and
solved with the same algorithm
how come well let's look at this each
one of those images
is actually a linear combination of two
different images where the only
difference is
the mask of weights used to combine
those images so for example
in the case of image segmentation okay
the two layers are the foreground layer
and the background layer
and the combining mask is just the the
combining weight is just the
segmentation mask
in this case it's a binary mask in the
case of transparent layer separation
here are the two layers and the combined
image
is just uh combined with a constant
mixing coefficient mask
and in the case of image dehazing the
two layers are the haste free image
and the fog air light color okay uh
but and the mixing coefficients are that
what's known as transmission map
which is inversely proportional to the
depth of scene points and the
atmospheric scattering parameters beta
now we don't have to know what they are
all we care about is that this is a
linear combination of two images
with some mask okay and these all can be
solved with what we
with an algorithm that we suggested we
call it double dip
in a moment you'll understand why it's
called double dip um
it's inspired by a work by julia
novadale which is called
deep image prior their work came out at
the same time as our zssr paper
the cdpr2018 and their ideas the
following given a single image
let's train a cnn to output this
particular image
so this cnn gets its input noise the
noise doesn't change over time
okay it may slightly fluctuate but it's
the same noise of throughout the
iteration and the network has to learn
to output this specific image
now of course it won't have any problem
it will eventually overfit this image
but the nice thing is when it does so
during the training process the weights
that the network learn
form a deep image prior on this specific
image
or in charge we call it dip okay
now why is this interesting well if you
train it if you train a dip on a noisy
image then yes eventually it will
overfit this noisy image but
interestingly
somewhere along the way it generates a
clean version of this image
how come well it turns out that the
patches in the clean image
have much higher recurrence much lower
entropy than in the noisy image remember
we said that patches tend to recur
inside the image well every patch here
will find many other similar patches in
the clean image
however if those two patches were the
same in the clean image
they're very different in the noisy
image so the patch distribution is much
more complicated than the noisy image
than it is in the clean image
and because a deep image prior is a
fully convolutional network
it tends to spit out the same things in
different parts of the image
okay because it uses the same kernels in
different parts of the image
and so it's much easier for it to
generate an image
with a simple distribution of patches
than an image with a complex
distribution of patches and that's why
it locks onto this much earlier than it
does onto this
now to verify our assumption we did the
following experiment
we took lots of pairs of textures and
combine them together to generate a
mixed texture
and now uh of course the attach entropy
in each one of those texture images
is lower than the patch entropy in the
mixed image
and now we train three different deep
image priors to try to learn each one of
those three images
and what you see here is how long it
took the deep image prior
to converge to each one of those images
and you can see that the green
curve here that's the one how long it
took a deep image prior to
to lock onto the mixed image it takes it
much longer it is much more difficult
for the deep image prior network to
learn a mixed image
than it is for it to lock onto the
orange
or blue images okay
so armed with this observation we said
okay we know how to split images
into their components using double dip
so here is a mixed image
let's train two deep image priors hence
double diff
so that the sum of these two uh uh
images will uh form the mixed image
okay now of course eventually we're
trying to fit this network to a single
image eventually it will overfit this
image
but interestingly when it does so it
tends to split the patches between those
two
deep image priors okay and the reason it
does so is because it's much easier for
each dip image prior to generate a
simple distribution of patches than
patches that are mixed that come from a
mixed distribution
and to further encourage them to do so
we add an exclusion loss
that penalizes for correlation between
patches among
these two reconstructed images and these
form are two recovered layers
now here we use the simple addition we
saw that in some tasks in
some of the tasks the mask is much more
complicated it's not a simple
uh mixing coefficient and so the
we uh we train a third network to learn
the mask
okay and that's the only difference
between these different tasks
is the kind of loss we tell we put on
the mask
okay so in the case of transparency
separation we encourage this mask
to be a uniform constant but if we want
to train it to do
image segmentation then uh we request
that the mask will be binary so we give
a loss on the mask but it should be
binary and we penalize it if it's not
so for example for this image eventually
the network
locks onto this image but when it did so
it
this was the mask it recovered and here
are the two layers it recovered and you
can see that one deep image prior
learned to spit out zebra patches and
one deep image prior learned to spit out
uh grass patches because this is the
simplest decomposition
into two simple distribution of patches
of the input image
okay uh so deep image prior has lots of
applications
for example image segmentation we took
many images
and we apply deep image power on each
input image individually trained it on
each double dip on each image
individually and here are the resulting
masks
that we got the segmentation masks now
remember
there is no semantic understand here no
labeling
no manual labeling and it's of course
not going to be as good as semantic
segmentation
with ground truth data but it does
things that are far from being trivial
it puts those two old ladies in a single
layer
along with their cards and the
background in a separate layer
it puts those three soldiers by the way
along with their uh
shadows in a single uh layer it put
you take it separates this image into
two textures
and it's simply because this is the
simplest decomposition
into two simplest distribution of
patches
uh we also apply double dip for doing
image dehazing
so here are hazy images now i want to
remind you that a hazy image is a linear
combination of the haze
free image and the fog air light with
the mixing
mask being the transmission map so here
are the recovered haze tree images
and here are the recovered transmission
maps which are inversely proportional to
the depth and you can see
bright here means close dark means far
and you can see that all of this
information was recovered from this
single hazy image by training only on
that image alone
if you look at this haze free image over
here you can see that all the grass has
much more or less the same color all the
the hay here is more or less the same
color this is not true for the hazy
image
okay so the distribution of patches here
is simpler the distribution of colors
okay um we can use it for transparency
separation this is a real video uh with
transparency
it's not it's not superimposed it's a
real recorded video
here the two recovered layers again
fully unsupervised
and you can see the resulting this is
indoor and this is outdoor
uh another form of transparency
separation is watermarks
uh and you can see here the this was the
input image here is the recovered
watermark and the
image itself uh and i want to remind you
that all of this
is done with no prior example simply by
training on the input image
carl can ask you a question so it's the
kind of thing that you would
uh if we were thinking about the
elephants and recordings of one elephant
talking over another
and you're trying to separate um that
would be an um
kind of if they would have look i didn't
try this on audio
right i don't want to promise but i i
would assume that if you
if the spectrograms i don't know one one
elephant of it over another
i don't know harm how much their patches
but maybe an older an
elephant and a younger one their patch
distribution within the spectrogram
might be sufficiently different to
obtain such a thing but this would
require of course
uh adapting this to audio data okay
we i'm just trying to think about then
what what is the noise and setting of
of sound and it's not perfect you know
there are many cases where it would
split things into things that you
wouldn't necessarily want
it just looks for the simplest split
into the distribution of patches
so there seems to be something really
strong about this
uh distribution of patches it's like
it's like a fingerprint of an
of an image and we want to say can we
somehow capture this gist of an
image can we take an image and generate
other images
of different sizes and aspect ratio that
have this same dna this
same patch distribution as the input
image
or in other words we want to capture and
retarget the dna of an image to generate
lots of other siblings with the same
patch distribution
and it turns out once again that this
can be done via an internal gan
so once again uh we train a generator
okay to generate these new images with
the same patch distribution
okay so our generator g is going to get
random sizes at each training iteration
and it's going to output images
according to those random sizes that we
uh uh
sample now initially they're not going
to look very good they're going to be
garbage
how can we guarantee that they come from
the same patch distribution
well we're going to feed crops from this
image
and from the original input image into a
discriminator that will try to tell them
apart and we'll try to say
which ones came from the real uh
distribution of patches in the input
image and which ones came from the
generated distribution of patches and
again it will generate the map saying
where it believes
things came from the original input
image and where if things came from the
generate
generated distribution and of course the
generator will use this mask to learn
how to improve
because it wants the discriminator to
think that everything came from the
input distribution and the discriminator
will try to get better think
whenever something is fed to it from the
generator will try to say that
everything is
false and whenever something is fed from
the input it will try to say that
everything is true
this is very easy when we feed those
crops we know which ones we gave him
the discriminator so we know the ground
truth label false are true
okay and uh uh
what could once they converge the
generator now becomes a network
that if you feed the input image into it
and any random size it will generate an
input an
image output image of this random size
with the same patch distribution as the
input image so here for example by the
way there's much more sophistication to
this but i have no time to go into
details so here's the input
image uh we asked the smaller image this
is
a certain size this is what it gave us
you can see that it's tripped off
uh windows it's stripped off uh uh
rows of windows it's stripped off bars
here from the barn in the back here
but all in all locally everything seems
as if it has come from the original
patch distribution the discriminator has
a small field of view it cannot tell
them apart
here is a large image and you can see
that it added many rows of windows and
many windows in each row
it added many more sticks here to the
barn but again
locally everything seems valid to the
discriminator
here is an image with a different aspect
ratio but it doesn't change the aspect
ratio of the elements inside the image
it doesn't grow them or shrink them it
just
multiplies them and of course we can do
it for any range of uh
of scales for example here's an an input
image
we can now generate and unfortunately my
screen is jumping which is really making
me mad because this is supposed to be a
smooth video
and it looks horrible but what you if
you look on my website you'll see that
this
smoothly goes uh you see that it doesn't
um
it shouldn't go like this uh
i don't know anyway sorry about this
this is
my office uh pc and the screen is
terrible uh but
you see that the the fruits don't grow
larger or smaller
it just gives birth to more fruits to
more boxes of fruits
you can see that it grows up it adds
rows of watermelons and so on
and we can also do this for any other
types of deformations
affine deformations and so on you can
see that still the patch distribution
remains the same it doesn't distort the
elements inside the image
we can take a uh a building add windows
to it
add rows of windows floors stories
uh everything is done using the same
train generator on the single image
uh we can add uh columns to the building
or we can uh take this penguin and you
can see the penguins don't grow any
fatter just the penguin gives birth
to new penguins okay and all generated
by training on the single
input image of course no one's perfect
uh our uh generator has no
notion of semantic understanding of
objects or scenes
it just tries to preserve the patch
distribution of multiple scales
and therefore would generate these kind
of images locally everything looks fine
to the discriminator
but globally it looks funny by the way
if we were to increase this
to further stretch this image it would
split it into two people
this is also what happens in the
penguins at some point you'll get
a penguin with two heads and then it
would split into two penguins
there's no way of avoiding this
here i want to show you uh something
totally new
what i call mind reading
how we can decode images recover back
images from brain activity uh this is
work that appeared in
europe's uh uh half a year ago and
since we published it there we had a
leap improvement in results together
with
neve gonorth and this is what i'll show
you here so we hope to publish this
uh soon in the journal this uh extended
version
but the idea is the following you have a
person lying in an fmri machine
watching images and the brain activity
is being recorded and we look at the
area of the visual cortex
and the question is can you recover can
you synthesize back
the input image from those readings in
the visual cortex not only can you
reconstruct it can you also classify the
image
say that this is a cheetah i don't know
okay
just from the looking at the visual
cortex now this is of course not a new
problem people have been looking at this
over more than a decade it started with
the amazing work of jack gallant and kay
and the solaris
and i'm not a neuroscientist they have
an amazing uh
set of work uh and the idea is given uh
pairs of images and their fmri
recordings
try to train a decoder okay to take the
fmris and decode it into images train it
on those images and then try to apply it
to new fmri
and initially those methods tried to do
this using linear regression between
fmri and images
and more recently people have started
doing this using deep learning methods
but the problem shared by all these
methods is there is simply insufficient
training data these data sets and we use
existing data sets we don't record the
fmri and ourself by ourselves
typically have a thousand two thousand
image uh and fmri pairs of data
that's far from being sufficient to
cover the space of all natural images
and you wanna be able to recover
uh a new image from an fmri of a never
before seen image
it's not like you can put you can put a
person that long in an fmri machine so
you can't
record too many images and it's not like
you can record images and show one
person those images and record this fmri
and show
more other images to another person
because these fmris brain from different
and
differ from brain to brain and uh
also the signal to noise ratio it's
terrible every voxel in the fmri covers
100 000 neurons averages information
over several seconds
that's excuse me shitty data we have
okay and that's what people have been
using and that's what we've also been
using
but we said hey let's add
self-supervision to this and the idea of
the following
on one hand we have those 1200
supervised examples
great we're going to use them we're
going to train two types of networks
a decoder that will learn how to decode
fmris into images and an encoder
that will learn how to encode images
into fmris
so initially we'll train them on those
1200 images of course they'll do great
on those 1 200 images and on those 1200
fmris
but they will not generalize well to new
images or to new fmris
but here is where the trick comes here
and here's where the self-supervision
comes
we're going to take those two networks
and stick them back to back
now this combined network its input is
an image
its output is also an image so if
trained well
then given any image it should be able
to output the same
image even though this image
we may have never recorded any fmri for
it
okay given that we don't need fmri we
can train it on as many images as we
want
tens of thousands of image net uh images
okay
from completely different statistics
that one the person saw in the fmri
machine
and we're not going to only ask that the
images will look the same
but we're also going to ask that the
semantic features extracted from those
images
on either side will be very similar okay
and that will guarantee that we
semantically recover meaningful
information including
new classes and so on that were never
viewed in the fmri
but we will do more than that we flip
the order of those two networks now the
input is an fmri signal and the output
is an fmri signal
and we can record train them on fmris
without knowing what the paired images
are at all
in particular we can train them on the
test fmri itself the test fmri that we
wish to decode
if trained well the output should be
equal to the input
so in our network we train those two
networks the decoder and encoder using
all these four
losses okay both uh training data
supervised information as well as
self-supervised information in both
directions
and by the way training on the test fri
gave us a huge
leap because it adapts itself to the
statistics of the new test data
so let's look at results what you see
here are the 50 test images in the data
set that we use
no cherry picking here you see a pair
left is the original image the person
saw right is the image we recovered from
the fmri readings
okay so here's a fish here you can see a
llama
the airplane uh this is some outdoor
scene
uh this is the cheetah
uh here's a boat or whatever canoe
a beer cup
fly yeah or this uh
ski uh the snow bike whatever it is
and of course we also get bad results
okay here you cannot recognize
anything uh i dare say and sometimes the
colors are off so there's still a lot of
place for improvement
but we're really excited about this and
we believe that we can do much more
i don't know if i have any time left i
have one last thing to show
but uh yeah but we have time for
questions afterwards
this will take me five more minutes
what's the what's the decision shafi
should i skip this or shall i show this
will compress the questions okay
all right so here we tried extending the
idea of deep internal learning to video
so far i showed you everything on images
and once again the first problem we
started looking at
is can we use this for temporal super
resolution zero shot temporal super
solution this is an upcoming paper
at eccv uh two weeks from now and the
idea is the following
in spatial super resolution we want to
increase the pixel density in the image
in temporal super resolution we want to
take a low frame rate video and increase
the frame rate take a 25 frame per
second video
and generate a 200 frame per second
video from it but we don't want to just
interpolate
we want to recover dynamic events that
occur faster than frame rate
and therefore are invisible in the
original input video that go beyond the
temporal nyquist limit of the
input video for example
you would want to be able to undo motion
blur and motion absolutely here's an
example of motion aliasing
this fan is rotating clockwise faster
and faster
but at some point because rotating so
fast it appears to be rotating
counterclockwise and this is simply
because we're
sampling it at 25 frames per second
that's not enough
for the temporal frequencies here and
also you see a lot of motion blur from
the moment the shutter opens
until it closes the fan moved a lot
generating this blur note that
interpolating in time
will not help resolve this problem it
will not do undue motion i will not undo
motion aliasing nor motion blur
temporal interpolation no matter how
sophisticated it is cannot undo these
effects
in super resolution and temporal super
resolution we want to be able to resolve
both of these effects and uh
we extend this idea of zero shot super
resolution from
images to space time and you can find
many details in our paper
but there are two very sophisticated
augmentations that we use in this case
okay one augmentation is generated by
blurring and sub-sampling the video in
time
okay what it does is it simula
so if this was the uh video in the
original uh
now note that the frames are have not
changed if this is the video in the
original temporal resolution
then this is uh the origin of the video
in the coarser temporal resolution
it's got more blur it moves faster and
at some temporal scale it will already
have
motion aliasing okay so going deeper in
temporal scales
synthesizes higher speed more motion
blur most marginalizing
from the input video we can now take
these pairs of
videos and train a deep network to learn
how to undo these effects
these video specific motion blurs and
motion aliasing and once trained
we can apply it to the input video to
generate the output video
another very uh sophisticated
augmentation that you can apply to the
input video and this is based on the
totally new observations of ours
that patches recur not only across
different scales
of the input image or input video but in
the case of video also across dimensions
of the video
what i mean by that is if you have a
space time volume x y t
of the video okay and then the spatial
slices of the space-time volume generate
our video frames
but if you now take the space-time
volume and rotate it
so that one of the spatial axis because
it becomes the temporal axis and now
slice it
but now you get space-time slices of the
video
now look at them you can see the cheetah
here they look quite similar to the
original video frames
but they have aliasing in time okay
because they weren't sampled fast enough
in time
however there's a lot of similarity
there is a lot of recurrence across
scales between the original video frames
and those temporal slices and therefore
we can use the high resolution examples
from the original
video frames in order to undo the
temporal aliasing
in the temporal slices and you can find
many more results
examples in our paper and explanations
but let me just show you results
of temporal super resolution by a factor
of eight
so here is the input video you saw
before here is uh
our result what you see here is nvidia
slo-mo
dane and flawless these are different
ways of interpolating in time or
super resolving and time videos that are
these are externally trained
ours is internally trained you can see
that they cannot handle motion blur
or motion aliasing here is another
example
uh this is the input this is our output
this is by the way the ground truth high
resolution
uh we generated the input from it and by
blurring subsampling in time and here
you can see the competitors
and you can see that we do better
of course it doesn't have to be
repetitive motion these are diamonds
falling
here is the input here is our output
and you can find many more examples on
our website including complex videos
like
splashing water flickering fire and
other things
so to summarize i hope i've convinced
you that
there's a lot of recurrence of
information inside visual data
and this gives rise to internal learning
generated image specific cnns
it combines the power of deep learning
with internal image specific or video
specific priors
it is totally unsupervised it needs
nothing but the input image
it adapts to the unknown image
conditions and degradations
it gives state-of-the-art super
resolution results on non-ideal images
but it can also be used for dehazing
segmentation transparency separation
retargeting and so on in an unsupervised
way
what's next can we use it for high level
vision tasks
video analysis beyond super resolution
um
can we apply can we combine the power of
internal learning and external
right now we train a network from
scratch for every new data
can we use prior knowledge on externally
provided examples and only
fine-tune it but it's not going to be
regular fine-tuning on the new
data and there are initial papers
showing uh but not by us
but by other people showing the power of
this combination
how can we apply it to other type of
signals audio
non-human communication i believe so
but it requires the proper adaptation
and i'd like to give
a credit to all the people who worked
with me uh
um
and figure pizzola and primarily a soft
chocolate was the main driving force be
put before behind all the deep internal
learning stuff
in the case of the fmri work uh the
people responsible for this are
roman bailly guy gazebranot assaf hobi
talgulan
and francesca stopini and uh
in the video temporal super resolution
it's worked
and thank you for your attention and i
hope i didn't take too much time
uh where signal to noise can be very low
it's a good question i'm now starting to
look at these things together with
people from biology at weitzman
i don't know yet i i will be smarter in
a year or so
but we are looking into this yes um
i have a few questions if i may one is
it safe to say
internal learning single image equals
external learning across patches
using symmetries and variances and
scale-free properties
i'm not sure i understood
um it's not the same i mean let me let
me
uh oh maybe i'll read the question all
the way to the end maybe i'll understand
it
will this only work for downscaling that
is symmetry preserving
such as linear translation invariant
down samplers there is a striking
similarity with max
entropy methods in image processing say
with wavelets
is the scale free uh property enforced
through such a criteria
first of all uh the downscaling we do it
is very similar to wavelets okay this is
this is regular gaussian pyramid but
wavelets are just different types of
pyramids
so i believe that uh there can be the
proper
recurrence in those cases okay and uh
and
it doesn't have to be only downscaling
we also found recurrences across
rotations and things like that there are
many geometric transformations
that will preserve uh this uh patch
recurrence
and if you look at our 2011 paper which
analyzes the internal uh statistics of a
single natural image
it looks at other types of
transformation and we said scaling
uh also flips are
uh and also rotations and there may be
others
uh also there are you don't necessarily
have to scale the same way if you have
an
edge let's say if you scale only
vertically
then i would still have the recurrence
even though you haven't scaled
horizontally or you can
so i believe that it's much more than
just what the kind of recurrences we
used
whether internal learning on a single
image is equal to external learning
across
patches i'm not sure i understand the
question maybe one of the panelists
understand the question but um
as i said each image has its own image
specific degradation for example super
resolution
you can train a single network to handle
all these degradations
if it will and you and also your data
for training may be different than
maybe you trained on uh natural images
but now you want to apply it to medical
images
that's different data it's not going to
be the same network
in the internal learning the advantage
is that the data you train on
is the data you want to apply it on okay
that's the advantage
but it's got its disadvantages of course
if you have lots of
external training data it's gonna it's
extremely useful
it will come it will and if it's good
training data it will be more powerful
than internal than simple internal
learning on a limited amount of data
so this is not to replace it's togement
the information that what we know to do
but when there's only very little data
to train on and the third question
are there any examples of incorrect
image decompositions
how frequently do they crop up oh of
course we have lots of examples of
of incorrect decompositions we're not
claiming uh that
by the way the dehazing decomposition
we're actually comparable to
state-of-the-art
image dehazing methods that were trained
with external examples
uniquely for this purpose we do
comparably well
image dehazing it does amazingly well
for the
image segmentation it's nowhere near
semantic segmentation
okay it does what it does sometimes
it makes sense and sometimes it doesn't
it just tries to find the decomposition
into two simple
distribution of patches but these may
not necessarily be the decomposition
that you want for example if you have
a horse and the background scene and the
background scene has
houses and trees and grass and people
and kids and uh dogs that i don't know
what
it won't necessarily maybe there's a
dog with the same color of the or
similar texture to that of the horse it
will probably put them together in the
same
layer it's not necessarily semantically
meaningful
okay so i think i answered all the
questions in the q a
again a wonderful talk and uh very
inspiring and
great results as usual i think well no
surprise that that
that you really had this uh legendary
reputation of
getting publications into any any
computer
in conference so thanks again for uh for
joining and
presenting